Selamlar sevgili dostlar. Umarım
iyisinizdir. Sağlık, sıhat yerindedir.
Ailenizle, sevdiklerinizle güzel bir
hayat yaşıyorsunuzdur. İş arıyorsanız
güzel iş fırsatları sizinledir. Şayet
eee iyi bir ekiplerde çalışıyorsanız,
çalıştığınız ekiplerde karşılığınızı,
emeğinizin karşılığını umarım
alıyorsunuzdur. Sizi anlayan ve
anlatabildiğiniz yöneticileriniz vardır
diyerek iyi niyetli başlayalım. Şimdi
hemen kola dönelim sevgili arkadaşlar.
Bugün sizlerle birlikte aslında
Refctoric Masterclass serisindeyiz. Eee,
Refactoric Masterclass serisinde şu an
7. videoya geçiyoruz. Hani ilk defa
gelen arkadaşlar vesaire varsa bütün
videolara zaten buradan erişebilirler.
Eee, şu ana kadar 6 seride işte projeyi
inceledik, kodlara baktık. Paket
mimarisi paket düşürdü. Şu herhalde
applicate olmuş ya da isminde bir hata
var. Onu düzeltirim. Eee, burada bir
yapımızı kurguladık. Eee, son olarak da
artık 6ıncısında arkadaşlar artık
projenin içerisine girdik ve mastercass
işte temizs diye başladım ve
sonuncusundan sonra artık prompt ve
skillerim de projeye entegre ediyor
oldum. Şimdi eee bu minimalde sevgili
arkadaşlar eee bu seferki videoda
sizlere aslında projenin en önemli
kısımlarından bir tanesi gerçekten çok
önemli olan kısımlardan bir tanes VV
Model Mix'in yapısını bahsedeceğim. Bunu
şu an hep paketsiz bir şey olmadan
anlatıyor olacağım ki fikri alın. Ondan
sonrasında işte widget compensation
dediğimiz aslında şu widgetların
parçalanmasından bahsediyor olacağım. Ve
akabin önümde şu an mesela halihazırda
olan login işte login response login
var. Bunların eee temiz koda çevirmiş
halini gösteriyor olacağım. Bunların
hepsini hazırladım. Prompllarını
hazırladım. Skillerini hazırladım ve
günün sonunda bunları rahatlıkla kendi
projelerinize alıp e hem burada izleyip
anladıktan sonra hem de kendi
projeninizi hızlıca o skillerle
kullanabiliyor olacaksınız diyorum
sevgili arkadaşlar. Şimdi eee prom için
teknik detayına hızlıca geçmeden önce
ben size önce buradaki sorunu biraz
hızlıca anlatacağım. Sonrasından da
çözüm mimarisinden gidiyor olacağız.
Şimdi arkadaşlar birçok projede bu ve bu
tarz mimarisel yaklaşımlar, hatalar
görüyorum. Burada en bariz problem
mesela bir page sayfasında, bir view
sayfasında flutter tarafında özellikle
mesela benim build dosyasına mesela
build metoduna ulaşamam. Mesela en büyük
proen bir tanesi bu. Ben göremiyorum şu
an. Bu ta aşağıda bir yerde mesela bir
problem burada bu. Bu yani aslında bizim
en basit matematikte view ve view'un
logiklerini ayırmamız lazım. Bakın
view'ın logicleri dediğim butona basmak
vesaire. Ama mesela Viven işte git
bekende de şunu kaydet. O weiv'ın
business'ı olarak geçer aslında. Şimdi
bunları ayırmayı burada yapmamız
gerekiyor. Birincisi. İkincisi yine bu
katmanların içerisinde asla işte
doğrudan bunları işte third party
paketleri kullanmamak lazım. Onu da
başka bir videoda zaten anlatıyor
olacağım. Bir o kısım var. Eee,
akabininde arkadaşlar view'ların
içerisindeki kodların da mesela şöyle
işte alt widgetlara işte kendilerine
özel komponentlere, subwidgetlara
ayrılıp daha okunaklı, daha erişilebilir
hale getirmesi lazım. Bunun için işte
part part part of'larla, viw structorile
oynayıp buraları temizliyor olacağız.
Eee, bunun akabininde şu an daha bunu
entegre etmedim ama lokalizasyon
desteğimizi entegre edeceğiz. Şu sized
box'ları bu şekilde kullanmayacağız.
Zaten bizim önceki videoda bahsettiğim
appsizer gibi paketlerimizi yazdığımız
kodlar vardı. Şurada mesela buradan
alacağız ki projenimiz structure
standart olsun. Eee ve akabinin de
bunların hepsini de yaptıktan sonrasında
ben buraya dönüp baktığımda sevgili
arkadaşlar ben login page neymiş ya
burası ne yapıyormuş deyip şöyle çok
mesela çok proje gördüm, çok kod gördüm
gerçekten hani böyle özellikle front
tarafta çok salla pati işte bir şey yok
deyip ya da UI'a baktığınızda şu an
şöyle baktığınızda saran bir UI olabilir
mesela belki hani şu an bir şey yok ama
eee ilerleyen matematikte diyelim ki bu
UI'ın işte ol güzel durmasından dolayı
ama arka taraf bu kadar kötü kodlarla
dolu olduğunu gördüm. Buna istinaden
aslında mesela böyle de yazılıyor mu abi
demeyin. Ben çok gördüm gerçekten bu ve
bu yaklaşımlar fikir olarak burada
mesela hani e bunların maplenmesi,
modellenmesi ki bunları da konuşuyor
olacağız işte her yerde böyle bu şekilde
bağlanması bunları çok gördüğüm için
özellikle bu videoda bahsediyorum. Şimdi
bunu bir matematiksel olarak kafamızda
tuttuk. Aslında sorun nedir? Aslında
temel olarak mantık nedir? Neyi yapmamız
lazım? Nereye gelmemiz lazımı? Aslında 3
be aşağı şu an kafamızda kurgulamış
olduk. Peki ne yapıyor olacağız? Şimdi
ben size zaten dediğim gibi artık
doğrudan bunların kodlarını bu refct
master class olduğu için zaten burada
size şeyi bahsetmeyeceğim. Hani bunu al
bunu çevir reför at abi oradan döndüğü
zaten öncesinden arkadaşlar ben size
bunun için mimari yaklaşımımı çözümü
hepsini hazırladım. Eee zaten artık
dediğim gibi bu videoların hepsinde daha
fikir vermeye gideceğim. Hani baştan kod
yazmaya gerek artık bu dönemde kalmadı.
Hepimiz de farkındayız. Fikri alalım.
fikri aldıktan sonra doğru promptlarla,
doğru textlerle kullanalım. Bu fikirleri
de geliştire geliştire projelerimizdeki
durumlara göre ilerletelim, büyütelim
diyor olalım. Şimdi arkadaşlar bakın
benim direkt yaptığım ve şu an prompt
hazır. Her şeyiyle birlikte önünüzde
olan değişiklik aslında direkt burada
gözünüzün önünde. Ya zaten şurayı insan
görü bile ferahlıyor önceki ne
düşündüğünüzde. Çünkü işte temiz bir
kullanım var. E viar parçalanmış.
Miksinim yapılmış model klasür. modelim
nerede biliyorum. View katmanlarım
nerede ben biliyorum. İşte view model
atılmış mesela bunun farkındayım. İşte
mesela page body diyerek işte loginin iç
sayfaları parçalanmış bunun farkındayım.
Yani benim aslında istediğim hemen hemen
her şey burada eee mimari yaklaşım
olarak burada benim elimde hazır ve ben
buradan kullanıyor oluyorum. Burada
mesela yine anlatacağım burada ne
yapacağımızı. Fazladan belki eklerdik
ama şimdi neyi değiştirdik mesela biz
artık? Biz artık bir kere başta demin
fark ettiniz bilmiyorum. Mesela
klasslarımızı final class atıyoruz.
daima yani inherit almıyorsak bir yerden
ki genel olarak flutter tarafında böyle
bir inheritance yapmıyoruz. O widget
compation yaklaşımı da oluyor zaten.
Sürekli alt widgetlara parçalıyoruz. Eee
bu noktada elinizden geldiği kadar
kodeksyona gitti ya. Elinizden geldiği
kadarıyla arkadaşlar e yapıları eee
parçalama ve final atarak hani onun
build time'da da performans sağlamasına
ve hem de basket bir klasanın iner
olmamasına dikkat ediyoruz. Şimdi bu
birinci kural. Şimdi ikinci kural
aslında benim en temel yaptığım şey
View'a baktığımda ben sadece View kodu
görmem lazım dediğim nokta burası. Yani
ben View'a bakıyorum işte app barım var
bilmem neyim var. Todarım atılmış işte
iç sayfalarım var. Buralar yönetilmiş ve
buradan sonra ilerliyor. Şimdi benim
burada login page body diye yaptığım
burada gördüğünüz aslında bir eee class
var burada. İşte bir birtım aslında sub
modüllerim var burada gördüğünüz. Burada
mesela şu an için toplu olması açısından
buraya ben koymuşum ama normalde bunu da
aslında şöyle yapmam. Mesela şuraya
geldiğinde şunu çıkartayım size daha
basit ve görmeniz açısından. Mesela
diyelim ki login test account info diye
bir alanım var. Ben onu gelirim buraya
normalde. Şöyle login test account info.
Çıkartırım ben buraya. Bunu da gelirim
arkadaşlar. Şuradan çok hızlıca bir tane
part of'umu veririm burada. Login page
body ile aslında direkt login page'le
olacak bu. Mesela burayla login page ile
şöyle veririm. Ardından da mesela buraya
geldiğimde arkadaşlar şurada widget
doğru mu verdim? View widget'ın
içerisinde partladım. Hı. Şunun part ofu
yanlış muhtemelen.
Şunu düzelteyim.
He bir tane daha attım. Tık geldi. Şimdi
bundan sadece bir tane daha olduğu için
ona kızıyor. Aslında burada bir en doğru
yaklaşım, en temiz olan yaklaşım dostlar
bunların hepsinin burada olması. Hatta
şöyle alırsam burayı kendisi de onunla
düzeltsin. Şu alt widgetların da mesela
ben alta şu an bütün komponentlerimi
parçalattım. Böyle parçalı widgetlarım
da böyle tek isterseniz sub widgetları
olarak oluşturabilirsiniz. Veya bu
şekilde private yaparsınız. Başka bir
klass erişilmez. çok hızlıca kullanılır.
Hem de kendisine özel alt widgetlar
kendi işlerini yapıp oyuna devam eder.
Yani bu en temel yaklaşım bir kere bu.
Bu herhangi bir bütün mimarilerde biz
alt videre böleceğiz. Privatlarımızda
yöneteceğiz. İç sayfa öldüklerini eğer
bir shared katma yani bir 34 sayfada
kullanacaklarsa bunu public bir yere
alacağız. Bir diğer ikincisine
geldiğimde şimdi arkadaşlar
incelememizde login page'e geldiğimizde
benim en önemsediğim nokta page
mixinler. Mixinleri hayatınızın bütün
widgetlarda kullanabilirsiniz burada
veya herhangi bir klassa. Mixin bir
abstract class aslında. Constructor
alamıyoruz. Buradaki temel mantalite
tamamen classın önüne yazdığımız bir eee
plugin gibi aslında. Yani onu entegre
özellikler verdiğimiz ve işte önem state
şunu da entegre ederek sadece bundan
türyanlar kullansın diyerek herhangi
birinin kafasına göre kullanamayacağı
bir yaklaşım. Buradaki en temel noktamız
viw'un kullandığı mesela controllerlar
eee işte varsa metotlar mesela şunları
kapatayım mı? metotlar. Bunların hepsini
burada topluyorum ki ben controller ne
yapıyor, view'um ne yapıyor buradan
göreyim diye. Tabii view logicleri
büyüdükçe çok fazla alt dala indikçe
business seviyesindekileri zaten
ayırıyorum. Ama mesela alt widget'larda
da butona bastım mesela onpress'te
loading olacak. Bunu kalkıp da kocaman
bir login page'i atmanın anlamı yok.
Zaten buton kendine onu yönetmeli gibi
bir karar da veriyor olacaksınız
ilerledikçe. Şimdi ben buraya tabi bu
metotlarımı koydum. Dispozularımı
hepsini ayarladım. Temiz bir şekilde
yine koydum. Burada önemli yaklaşımdan
bir tanesi yine benim size önereceğim ve
yapmanız gereken çok set state kurumları
görüyorum. Alt widget mesela butonun
loading state çok basit bir durum ve bir
yönetim var. Burada set state
yönetirsiniz ama sayfa ve sayfanın
içerisinde durumlar oluşma eee yönü
varsa bu noktada bir state management
vesaire de girmediyseniz ki ilk başta
girmeye gerek yok zaten oldukça
yeterlidir. Mesela Value Notifier ve
Value Notifier'ın önünü yazacağınız
basit bir immutable class. Burada
gördüğünüz üzere hatta bunun başına eee
şöyle bunlara comment atmaya gerek yok
bu arada da o dümenden sallamış. Şöyle
atayım şuraya. immutable bir class
yapmanız sayesinde aslında doğrudan
kocaman objeleri işte set state set
state demek yerine aslında sayfanızı da
çok basit bir şekilde value notifyile
yöneteceğiniz bir obje yaratıyorsunuz.
Mesela bunu kullanan burada kim? Mesela
state'i kullanan burada state'i burada
set eden var mı? Mesela şurada mesela
state'in herhangi bir mesela state'i
görüyor musun? Value demişim. State.
Valuue git kardeşim copy with'le
güncelliyorum. Bu güncelleme olduğunda
otomatik olarak view'da bunu dinleyen
varsa value disenable boulder'la
otomatik olarak triggerlanmış olacak
mesela. Ya bu da güzel bir kullanımdır.
Temiz bir kullanımdır ki burada da
gördüğünüz yatın oldukça temiz bir
kullanım var. Eee diyelim ki bu arada
şunu da özellikle göstermek istiyorum.
herhangi bir dediğim gibi kullanmak
zorunda değilsiniz. Bu sektör ya bu
flutter camiasında çok aşina bir şekilde
size state management pompalanır. Bunun
çok bir anlamı yok. Çünkü logik ve alana
göre her şey yeterlidir. İhtiyaca göre
kod yazılır. Her hayatın hep böyledir.
Yani kalkıp üç satırlık projeyene kalkıp
kocaman bir klinik tektiri yapmanın
hiçbir anlamı ve kimseye yararı yok. Eee
burada testler çok daha basit testler
yazıp olayını çözebilirsin. Ondan dolayı
mesela burada benim size göstereceğim
basit bir mesela V model katmanı ve
hiçbir özelliği yok. ekstrası yok.
Sadece bir class ve içerisinin
metotlarını koymam benim neyi sağlıyor
biliyor musunuz? Dönüp baktığımda vivum,
vivo'un mixini, mixinimde vivo'un
logikleri var. Benim vom'un
businessları, business nedir? İş yani
login, log successful, save to user
cash, login komutu işte bunlar varsa
bunları da düncelleyeceğiz ama bu basit
fikir olarak yani view fikir olarak bu
gayet yeterli. Bunlar da burada olmalıyı
söylemem gerekiyor. Mesela söyledim.
Tamam. Burası benim nerede ne olduğunu
biliyorum artık ve en azından gideceğim
yere ve nereye koşacağımı biliyorum
diyerek hani bunu da söylemiş olum. Yani
böyle bir klass oluşturup içerisine
toplarsanız tadından yenmez yine
objeleriniz. Ha diyeceksiniz ki abi
bunlar işte çok en alt classız widgetlar
onların zaten o state management o
noktalarda size çok yardımcı olacak.
Onları da konuşuyor olacağız. Bu en
primitif, en basit bir şekilde çok
temizleyebileceğiniz ve bütün widget
view'larınızın herhangi bir view değil
aslında herhangi bir stateful class,
herhangi bir stateless classa çok
rahatlıkla entegre edebileceğiniz
çözümleri ben size şu an gösteriyorum.
He eminim ki çok fazla yerde sizin
işinize yarayacak bu yani bu yöntemler.
Yani mesela böyle part part part
of'larla alt classları ayırıp işte
ilgili objelere ilgili alanları verip
valinable
builder'la kullanmak işte objeleri temiz
tutmak finaları atmak bunları immutable
sonra model oluşturup modelin içerisinde
şu mesela login response model şu an
daha içerisine girmedim bir sonraki
videoda var anlatıyor olacağım işte
servis katmanını ve model katmanlarını
düzelteceğim eee onu mesela bu yanlış
bunu da düzeltiyor olacağız ama mesela
benim straight objemin içerisinde var
mesela straight'i ben düzgün bir şekilde
yaptım Imut table olması çok önemli.
Referansların kaymaması ve işte birden
fazla obje set ettiğin ya da bir
durumunda bunların işte problem yaşamama
açısından eee oldukça önemli mutable
olması. Bunları set ediyoruz. Eee bunun
dışında mesela burada login view modulu
set ediyoruz. Login page'i zaten
topladığımızı söylemiştim. Mesela
buradaki objelerimizi topladık. Eee işte
V modul'u, page mix'ini, body'yi
ayırdık. Aslında temel olarak arkadaşlar
bir herhangi bir Flutter View'u şu
parçalamayı yaptığınız sürece tertemiz
ilerlersiniz. Oldukça çok güzel bir
yaklaşımdır. Aslında biz ne yapmış
olduk? View'umuzu aldık. Dağınık. İç içe
olan kodlarımızın hepsini dışarı
çıkardık. Response modelimizi çıkardık.
Modelin altına işte widget diye klasör
oluşturup private'larımızı koyduk.
Body'yi koyduk. Üstüne bir tane de mixin
yapısı kurgulaylarak wew'ın logiklerini
ayırdık. State koyarak da hatta VI'ı
daha da iyi hale getirdik. Set state'ten
kurtardık. İhtiyacı olan yerler
tetiklensin dedik. Son olarak da login V
model gibi bir ufak layer yazarak da
hiçbir management olmadan çok basit bir
şekilde business dediğimiz o katmanı
yani işte işte backendedir, oydur
yönetiyorduk. E ve ben günün sonunda bir
developer olarak buraya geldim
baktığımda ne nerede nasıl gitmiş ne
yapmışı çok rahatlıkla görüyor
kullanıyor oluyorum burada sevgili
arkadaşlar. Şimdi bu benim size
vereceğim ana fikir zaten burada bu.
Bunu diyelim ki siz kullanmak
istiyorsunuz sizin için. Ben şimdi
duruma göre korda kullanıyorum. CL'de
kullanıyorum. Ceminde kullanıyorum.
Bunun hiçbir önemi yok. Önemli olan
prompt ürettiğim yer ve alan. Şimdi ben
size dokümanın altında arkadaşlar
promptın altında view refactor diye bir
tane prompt oluşturdum. İsterseniz bu
view e refactor promptini alırsınız.
Herhangi bir sayfanızda sadece view bu
promptu alıp işte bana view işte a
view'ını düzelt demeniz bu promptu
kullanmak için yeterli. Hani bu promptu
kullanmak için başka bir şey yapmanıza
ihtiyacınız yok. Hatta bu videoyu
izleyen bir arkadaş isterse diğer
sayfaları düzeltipini atabilir ama şu
prompt sizin için oldukça yeterli
olacaktır. Aslında benim yaptığım her
şey bu promptun içerisinde var. Bir de
ben sizin için mesela cloudu da bilerek
git ignore koymadım görün diye. Bir de
skill oluşturdum. Bu skil de alıp
herhangi bir projede yine herhangi bir T
anında kullanarak kendinize temiz eee bu
yapıyı alıp kullanabilecek hale getirmiş
olursunuz. Mesela ben daha neleri
ekledim? App size alsın. Mesela işte
sayfada varsa kan işte statik kullanılar
onları websaydan okusun. İşte buralara
temalar gelsin falan filan. Bunların
hepsini promptın içerisine, skillerin
içerisine eklemeye çalıştım. Bunları da
buraya oluşturdum. İsterseniz bu
prompları, skilleri de kullanarak
sayfalarınızı çok temiz bir şekilde
bağlayıp ilerletebilirsiniz arkadaşlar.
Eee diyorum. Hatta şimdi bu yaptığımızı
da şöyle son olarak sevgili arkadaşlar
komitledim. Şu yaptığımızı son halini
bir alayım.
Hop komitimi tamamladım. zaten direncimi
oluşturmuştum. Tudi'ya geliyorum. Şimdi
planlananlardan arkadaşlar şu V7'nin
birincisi sıralamayı birazcık
değiştirdim çünkü eee daha önemli
olduğunu düşündüğüm için VV model mixini
anlattım. Şimdi bir sonrakinde serbest
bir modele geçeceğim. Şu duplicate olmuş
düzelteceğim. Sonra biraz state
management böyle böyle bu projeyi
kurtaracağız ve günün sonunda elimizde
birçok prompt, birçok skill oluşacak ve
bunları kendimize göre entegre ediyor
olacağız demiş olayım sevgili
arkadaşlar. E teşekkür ediyorum
tekrardan dinlediğiniz için. Umarım bir
fikir olmuştur. PR'ını atıyorum şu an
itibariyle. İsteyenler PR'dan bakabilir.
İsteyenler benim dediğim gibi diğer
sayfalar entegrasyon yapabilir. Bana PR
atabilir. Onu duruma göre bakarsınız
zaten. Şimdiden arkadaşlar elinize
emeğinize sağlık. E kolay gelsin
diyorum. Görüşmek üzere bir sonraki
diğer videoda. Şunu da hemen PR'a
bastım. Yes. Tamamdır. Görüşürüz sevgili
arkadaşlar. Yeah.